H
KAYLEIGH McENANY,
JULIE BANDERAS, CHERYL CASONE,
JIMMY FAILLA.
WE BEGIN.
DR. MEHMET OZ IS LEAVING JOHN
FETTERMAN AND THE PENNSYLVANIA
SENATE RACE JUST FOUR DAYS
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
A NEW POLL GIVING THE REPUBLICAN
OR TWO-POINT ADVANTAGE IN WHAT'S
BECOME A NAIL-BITER OF A RACE.
OZ WILL NOT HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
THE WOMAN WHO HELPED LAUNCH HIM
TO TV STARDOM.
THAT WOULD BE YOUR GIRL,
OPRAH WINFREY HORN ANNOUNCED HER
ENDORSEMENT OF FETTERMAN LAST
NIGHT AND SPEAKING OF STAR
POWER, BOTH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA WILL HOLD
A RALLY WITH FETTERMAN TOMORROW
IN PHILADELPHIA.
OBAMA WILL ALSO JOIN FETTERMAN
AT A RALLY IN PITTSBURGH.
LAST HOUR ON THE VIEW, FETTERMAN
HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT HIS
HEALTH, TRANSPARENCY AND REFUSAL
TO RELEASE MORE MEDICAL RECORDS.
>> NOT THE EQUIVALENT KIND OF
MEDICAL INFORMATION AS DR. OZ
DID.
HE EVEN RUNNING CAMPAIGN AND I
THINK WE HAVE BEEN VERY
TRANSPARENT.
OUR DOCTORS BELIEVE.
FROM JUNE AND IN OCTOBER, THEY
AGREE THAT I'M FIT TO SERVE.
TO ME, NOT THE POINT
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT MY HEALTH.
I FEEL WE ARE RUNNING A VERY
TRANSPARENT RACE ABOUT OUR
HEALTH ISSUES.
>> I THINK YOU LOOK AND SOUND
GREAT.
>> Emily: AND THAT'S ALL THAT
MATTERS, JIMMY.
THE SEAL OF APPROVAL.
>> Jimmy: GOOD TO SEE
EVERYBODY.
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS RACE
CLOSELY.
I HAVE A LOT OF FAMILY IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
BIG DRINKERS.
YOU WOULD BE TOO IF YOU ARE A
PIRATES FAN.
FETTERMAN'S HEALTH WAS NEVER
GOING TO BE THE ISSUE.
ITS HIS POSITION ON THE ISSUE.
NOBODY AT HOME HAS ANY ISSUE
WITH THE FACT THAT PEOPLE GO
THROUGH DEBILITATING CONDITIONS
AND IN SOME INSTANCES ARE UNABLE
TO COMPLETE A SENTENCE.
IT'S THE FACT THAT HE DOESN'T
WANT VIOLENT CRIMINALS TO
COMPLETE THEIR SENTENCES THAT
HAVE PEOPLE LEANING TOWARDS
DR. OZ.
WHERE OPRAH COMES INTO THIS
WHOLE MESS AND SHE'S NOW PART OF
THE CONDESCENDING CLASS.
SHE'S PART OF THE LIBERAL
ELITES.
YEAH, SHE WAS FRIENDS WITH
DR. OZ HER WHOLE LIFE BUT NOW
SHE'S PART OF THE CLASS OF
PEOPLE THAT SAYS REPUBLICANS ARE
EVIL.
THEY ARE LESS TRUE THEN, TOO
STUPID TO KNOW WHAT'S GOOD FOR
THEM SO I AM WITH FETTERMAN,
WHICH IS ABSURD, BUT THAT'S WHAT
SHE'S BECOME.
>> Emily: KAYLEIGH, I WANTED
TO DRILL DOWN.
DOES IT MATTER WHO OPRAH
ENDORSES?
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S NOT
UNEXPECTED.
SHE ENDORSED EVERY DEMOCRAT IN
EVERY STATE, INCLUDING STACEY
ABRAMS, EVERYONE.
THE QUESTION IS, I THINK WHAT
MATTERS MORE AND WHAT --
THE EDITORIAL BOARD OF THE
"PITTSBURGH POST-GAZETTE" WHO
ISSUED THEIR ENDORSEMENT AND ON
LIKE OPRAH, ACTUALLY ARTICULATED
REASONS WHY.
THEY TALKED TO THE LACK OF
EXPERIENCE OF FETTERMAN.
THEY TALK TO THE FACT THAT OZ
HAS COMMITTED TO CIVILITY, HAS
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO WORK WITH
THE OTHER SIDE.
THEY REALLY NAILED DOWN A WHOLE
LIST OF WHY THEY WERE ENDORSING
OZ OVER FETTERMAN AND I VENTURE
THAT GOES FURTHER WITH
PENNSYLVANIANS IN OPRAH'S
ENDORSEMENT.
>> Kayleigh: I DON'T THINK
ENDORSEMENTS MATTER GENERALLY
EDIT GENERAL ELECTION.
THEY MATTER IN PRIMARY.
SOUTH CAROLINA.
TRUMP ENDORSED CANDIDATES IN
PRIMARIES.
I DON'T THINK THEY MATTER IN A
GENERAL.
TO YOUR POINT, EMILY, ESPECIALLY
THE OPRAH ENDORSEMENT, THIS WAS
COURTED FOR WEEKS BY THE
FETTERMAN CAMPAIGN.
THEY SAID THEY KNEW THEY POWER
OF A HILLARY ENDORSEMENT.
WE SAW THAT POWER WHEN SHE
ENDORSED HILLARY CLINTON.
WHAT IS PARTICULARLY IRONIC IS
FETTERMAN TOTING A CELEBRITY
ENDORSEMENT AS HE TRIED TO
DERIDE DR. OZ FOR BEING A
CELEBRITY WHILE AT THE SAME
TOKEN HE'S TRYING TO ENDORSE --
TRYING TO TOUT THIS ENDORSEMENT
FROM JOHN LEGEND WHO WANTED TO
DEFUND THE POLICE.
NONE OF IT MATTERS.
HIS IRONY IN ENDORSING A
CELEBRITY, TOUTING IT, GOING
AFTER OZ.
WHAT MATTERS IS HIS RECORD.
TEN FIRST-DEGREE MURDERERS
BECAUSE OF FETTERMAN'S VOTE.
HEROIN INJECTION SITES.
HE APPLAUDED OREGON FOR
DECRIMINALIZING ALL DRUGS
INCLUDING HEROIN AND FENTANYL.
HE GOT AN ENDORSEMENT FROM A
GROUP WHO WANTS TO TAKE SEX OFF
BIRTH CERTIFICATES, ILLUMINATING
FRACKING.
>> Emily: CAN FETTERMAN SAVE
HIMSELF?
WHEN THE PRESIDENT FLEW TO
PITTSBURGH TO CAMPAIGN FOR HIM,
HIS WIFE TURNED AWAY REPORTERS.
ISN'T ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS
BUT NOW FOR SOME REASON HE'S
GOING ON THE SMALL MEDIA TOUR.
ENJOYING HIMSELF ON "THE VIEW.
GOES WITH THE SAME GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO LAUGHED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT HERSCHEL WALKER
MIGHT HAVE BRAIN DAMAGE FROM HIS
YEARS PLAYING PROFESSIONAL
FOOTBALL.
THEY MOCKED DeSANTIS FOR
"LOOKING LIKE HE HAD A STROKE."
BUT TODAY JOY BEHAR WAS APPALLED
THAT PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT FETTERMAN
HAS BEEN FACING AND SAID IT'S ON
EMPATHETIC.
WE HEARD SONNY HOSKINS, YOU LOOK
AND SOUND GREAT.
IT SEEMS TO ME THERE'S NOT ONLY
HYPOCRISY THERE BUT ON HIS AND
UNWILLINGNESS TO BEGIN WITH
REPORTERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PRESS THAT WOULD ACTUALLY ASK
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS AND NOT
JUST WAIT AROUND.
>> THEY ARE COVERING FOR THEIR
CANDIDATE, OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S NOT JUST FETTERMAN.
PEOPLE WHO QUESTION THOSE WHO
ARE FAIR AND BALANCED THE MENTAL
CAPACITY OF OUR PRESIDENT BUT
YOU WOULD NEVER HEAR THAT ON
"THE VIEW POST QUOTE OR ANY
OTHER MAINSTREAM MEDIA NETWORK.
I WANT TO BRING UP THE DEBATE
BETWEEN FETTERMAN AND OZ, IT'S
LARGELY LEANING TOWARD CRIME IN
THE WAY THAT FETTERMAN TREATS
CRIME.
IN THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA,
THE LAW SAYS THAT PROSECUTORS
CAN BRING A CHARGE OF FELONY
MURDER.
IT'S ALSO KNOWN IN THE STATE'S
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER, IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE SOMEBODY GOING OUT
AND INTENTIONALLY KILLING 70.
IF YOU ROB SOMEBODY AND THEY
FALL AND THE END OF DYING FROM,
YOU KNOW, A FALL FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU WOULD BE CHARGED WITH
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER, MANDATORY
LIFE SENTENCE.
JOHN FETTERMAN IS AGAINST
MANDATORY LIFE SENTENCES.
NOT ONLY DOES THE STATE NOT HAVE
THE DEATH PENALTY BUT IF YOU
COMMIT MURDER, WHETHER IT'S
FIRST-DEGREE OR SECOND DEGREE,
YOU SPEND THE REST OF YOUR LIFE
BEHIND BARS AT THE VERY LEAST.
JOHN FETTERMAN WANTS THEM BACK
OUT.
HE WANTS MURDERERS NOT TO BE
MANDATORY LIFE SENTENCE.
HOW DO YOU EVEN JUSTIFY THAT?
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND.
>> Emily: ALSO AGAINST MINIMUM
SENTENCING IN GENERAL WHICH HAS
BEEN CODIFIED AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
THERE'S A CASE BEHIND EVERY
SINGLE RULE THAT WE HAVE.
THERE'S A REASON A HEARTBREAK,
TRAGEDY BEHIND THE REASON WHY IT
WAS CODIFIED SO THAT THOSE
RECIDIVISTS, SO WE DON'T HAVE A
JUDGE SAYING "I'M SORRY.
MY HANDS ARE TIED.
I AM SORRY YOUR LOVED ONE GOT
TORTURED AND RAPED TO DEATH."
THE OP-ED ON FOX NEWS, HIS
APPROACH TO CRIME, THAT WAS SORT
OF ABOUT ATTACKING OZ AND
FRANKLY AND OVERGENERALIZING
OVER STUPEFIED WAY.
HE WASN'T MAKING AN ARGUABLE
CASE WHATSOEVER OF HER'S
POLICIES IN FACT IT SEEMED AS IF
HE WAS FLIP-FLOPPING AND TALKING
ABOUT HOW SAFE HE HAD MADE
THE TOWN HE WAS THE MAYOR OF,
IN STARK CONTRAST TO STATISTICS
AND WHAT PENNSYLVANIANS SAY.
>> FLIP-FLOP IS AN INTERESTING
WORD TO USE.
DEBATE TURNED THE TABLES FOR
FETTERMAN.
THIS NEW EMERSON COLLEGE POLL.
2% LEAD FOR DR. OZ.
IN PENNSYLVANIA, FRACKING IS A
BIG ECONOMIC, JOBS, KITCHEN
TABLE ISSUES TO VOTERS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS ALL BOILS DOWN TO WHAT THEY
WANT.
WHAT THEY WANT TO SOMEONE THAT'S
GOING TO SUPPORT ENERGY
PRODUCTION IN THEIR STATE, JOBS
AND THEIR STATE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA GOING TO
PENNSYLVANIA TOMORROW IS THAT
IT'S THE CLIMATE AGENDA THAT HAS
COME FROM BOTH OF THOSE LEADERS
THAT ACTUALLY LEAD TO THE JOB
DESTRUCTION WE HAVE SEEN IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
LESS ENERGY PRODUCTION IN
GENERAL IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S ISSUE NUMBER ONE.
YOU MENTIONED THE DR. OZ --
ABOUT THE FACT THAT HE WAS
ENDORSED BY THE "PITTSBURGH
POST-GAZETTE."
THEY TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
HE'S GOT A BUSINESS BACKGROUND,
LEADERSHIP BACKGROUND.
20 YEARS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT OZ'S CELEBRITY,
THEY POINT OUT.
IT'S ABOUT THE FACT THAT OZ IS
BRINGING "I CAN GO TO WASHINGTON
AND BE A GOOD LEADER FOR YOU."
PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
>> Jimmy: SHAME ON OPRAH
BECAUSE SHE KNOWS THAT ABOUT
DR. OZ.
SHE TOUTED HIM.
SHE TOUTED HIS BUSINESS
PROFICIENCY.
THAT'S WHY IT WON'T WO